Louisiana's postal master plan calls for
the state to spend fifty billion dollars
over 50 years preserve its weapons
some of that will come from the
government more than six billion dollars
will come from the BP oil spill seven
the state loses a football field worth
of Post every hour
marshland is the mainland's first line
of defense ship Klein says his mandate
is to make sure there's more of it
he points to by you do pond
a contractor is piping in sediment from
the Mississippi River 15 miles to create
new marshland another way to move
sediment is with what are called river
diversions there's a growing chorus of
criticism folks who live here along the
Gulf Coast to work in small businesses
who are shrimpers fishermen oystermen
were worried about the installation of
River diversions like the one behind me
that allow the Mississippi River to flow
into the marshlands that's one component
of the master plan one critic is
fisherman George risks if day duties for
these large-scale really demanding
projects we will be out of business for
good Rick's worries that a new diversion
will hurt the fishery and his livelihood
what are we traversing right now this is
Bayou loot by Lulu tree that is about 30
miles from a river diversion that was
built before Hurricane Katrina look out
over that Marsh you see how thick and
lush it is yeah it's all one piece you
don't see any openings now watch where
we're going
will Bob Dinneen miles from where we
left from it from the dock we're about
maybe 8 miles 10 miles maybe from the
diversion right there she doesn't know
there's no root system at all ship
Rick's blames that on the influx of
fresh water
he says he's for coastal restoration
that the government does not understand
this fragile ecosystems and components
Louisiana will revise the coastal master
plan in 2017 Louisiana's postal
Authority says residents like risk will
have a seat at the table